[Music]
for
what you see
there
I tried to show you
different things okay so let's look at
one part that's troubling
you this
part
see what do you see happening to my
base not what it's checked I think it is
checked you see I think it is checked
you see
it watch the solution though it's not
check myself
[Music]
more not
here
his energy is G that way you're pushing
it let it keep going that way right
around
you
okay you go like this it's already
there you can light in the
elbow how much is
there couple
ways 10 con
more yield more
but as opposed to
this there's too much elbow coming
actually M his elbow
up
here like you're going cut in his
head you're you're not worried about his
elbow yet
[Music]
cut
same cut even though I'm touching the
elbow don't push on it yet cut his head
heel counter
it got light
now if he tries to go around the
throwing energy it exposes the
elbow
you can take some off here in there goes
around take some off here counters goes
[Music]
around
yield attack counter
right
so we'll do I know how to light in this
one now we're doing this one it's not
here it's over
here and you going do the same
thing it goes around you it goes around
you around you around you around
you
f
here I'd like you to
notice you don't have to do
that you don't have to do
this got and go
in do the same
thing the
internal
come you understand don't get trapped
extra watch my legs now this is a marker
okay cuz usually what happens is you
overpower you see and like you saw oh I
got to do something else so I come over
here watch my legs
boom
boom they're always on this on his
Center Line you see that as opposed
to
OU
I'm not fighting
him soot is going to let the young
energy through me so I don't want to
deviate around it like in the UR do you
understand so as in com we already know
there's that
strike but there's no there's no
resistance on it I don't have an angle
that he could push on you
see so you already have a top CER
and you're going to have that
repeatedly so Bo pop is right there boom
boom is the other one and as you come
through boom is the other
one Center HP
boom
I just want you to look at my feet for a
few reps okay and and my hand work on
the first one Center HP Center
in
Center PP
PP now bring your attention back from my
hands and you see that I still have to
have this the curves to allow me to do
that okay so I'm still doing the
curves so there's still
the a aspect is still in there but it's
not without the
penetration
potential
in in
in
now see if you can observe
both okay try it so uh again that's
generally the external aspect of it okay
but you you can't even do the external
aspect of it without the internal aspect
okay so for example those kicks I were
showing if I was pushing on him
externally I wouldn't be able to raise
my feet okay which some of you experien
so we did a Gateway video on this
okay so here is his resistance of his
elbow represented here you see and if I
try to walk I I will take myself off
balance okay but when when I learn the
ground Then I then I can walk okay so
I'll demonstrate it in the
form but do do you know where you were
doing it what I'm talking about your
foot kind of flows so you're you're here
and you're like
who kind of hangs there okay as as
opposed to you don't need your base do
you see I didn't need the the brace and
angle base because the energy is being
vectored down do you see that so you
didn't see a big deviation you can see
my kick still come around and I still
block him around
okay
um so going to the energetic one you you
want to play with your I and your
CQ and you want to play with
the the the in between the lional state
of Yin and Yang aspects that's where you
want to hang out okay and that's where
the ik is so I internally I'm letting
his energy go through
me down to the ground the young aspect
is being generated by him her
prescription and I let that ground and
go in me so I want you to pay attention
now how I'm not really interested in Arm
Control okay I you'll see that because
I'm just interested
energetically what concentrically
happens is I'm actually manipulating his
body you see because his young aspect is
more in his body than in his hand
especially at the distal end okay so if
you if you watch I'm kind of inside his
movement and he's going around me well
I'll keep the external part the same
okay so here
boom
just watch his body now his body
body
and you'll see I kind of like surfing
the tube surfing the
tube
all that is possible because
his energy is not actually pushing on
me it is going around me it is going
around
me but if I do that externally you won't
get your feet you won't be able to move
you can't stay up with him you see you
have to wait for him to go off of you
off of you and then you
enter because you had to wait for it to
go off of you to enter you're reduced to
fighting the arm not the person or you
couldn't kick if you wanted to kick
okay
the point of the training is to not feel
here it's not to pin his elbow
f
there is
a spiritual aspect to it as we've been
mentioning my
body when it enters the limal state of
the yin and yangong
aspects my two minds will concentrically
Rec
reconcile but there's also a marshall
one so I already showed it you wouldn't
be able to
kick if he's heavier he's going to
compromise your base you're going to
have to pull all this kind of stuff
okay but what you're not
realizing
is the mechanical advantage you perceive
is not actually there okay
so I am not a big man but I am much
stronger than you okay so she comes
around go ahead it's fine I won't even
deal with the inertia here we go
go what I'll give you here okay push
down push
down so again I'm not
trying
you could do this
push and in that I can do my stuff of
course
I picked that one because it seems like
oh so able to do it but
no okay you want to
have nothing here in the
ground nothing here in the ground so
resist resist not
here you get it through me and around
again
resist resist
no through
me I don't push on
it okay try it again okay so my my
research and my personal practice
experiences that all premodern
Technologies of the self what they're
what they're trying to do is get you in
what Scholars of religion have called
the linal state uh when you get into a
Lial State you then have the uh what I
call the ego tripartite mind it'll slow
stop deconstruct stop driving your
agency okay put you in the mystical
state so in iido for
example uh you're always going to have
the physical
component but you're going to always
have the internal component okay you
wouldn't do like a lot of I would say
contemporary taiichi where they try to
take out the external component all the
time uh I'm all for doing that so that
you can see what is actually happening
at the internal level but I'm not not
for that that's the way okay you do want
to move you want to have your external
level concentrically manifesting the
internal uh level so for R3 components
you would always have the physical
component being concentrically
manifested and vice versa at the
energetic component do you understand we
we are not shooting for one or the other
okay so if you have modern iido and
you're all external I'm going to say no
because you can't enter a Lial phase
with one aspect and if we have the
internal people and all they do is stand
still and try to get everything to go
through them I would say no as well uh
because you're not into the in into the
Lial aspect of these Technologies on how
they function do do you understand that
okay
so um but it is helpful to take away as
much external so that you could see ah
something else is going on like right
right um now probably the UK is the only
one that could feel what he's feeling so
it's like he's it's not I don't know
what I'm feeling because he's not really
there there's not really resistance but
my body is moving all over the place it
feel we try to describe it it feels
light it feels void you know these are
all poetic Expressions okay so uh what
we're going to do now is as he comes
in do e without any movement okay so I
can't now take off externally any of
that energy that that energy has to pass
through me
this is that same energy that when I
first showed you like yeah that would
push me
too this is the same energy from your
cud drills that I don't let that energy
push through me and now just doing it in
what you would
recognize as
[Music]
a and I do this so you can see I there's
a there's a lot of circles
around everything do you see that
remember that first
part just
around
[Music]
I force it everything stops he pushes me
back cuz he weighs more than me okay so
try it again